un avion qui le tour de la terre
pour des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'argent comme le dit Jacques
Bissonnet.
- Décollage réussi hier soir
pour les 4 touristes américains,
dont le milliardaire
Jared Isaacman qui a affrété
le vol.
Ils passeront 3 jours autour
de la Terre, plus loin que
la Station spaciale
internationale.
Chaque jour, ils feront environ
15 fois le tour du globe.
Un été marqué par deux autres
vols de milliardaires,
Richard Branson à bord
de Virgin Galactic et plus tard
de Jeff Bezos avec sa société
Blue Origin.
Mais à quoi sert ce tourisme
spatial?
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ,
astrophysicien
- On a l'impression que ca sert
les plus fortunés d'entre nous,
mais après donc le tourisme
spacial il faut se poser
la question, bien : où est-ce
qu'on va aller plus loin?
Est-ce réservé uniquement à
ces gens-là? Mais il faut se
poser des questions sur le coût
écologique, le coût social de
ce genre de missions.
- Cette mission, baptisée
INSPIRATION 4, servira également
à approfondir les connaissances
sur le corps humain.
Des analyses seront effectuées
sur le rythme cardiaque
des passagers, sur leur sommeil
ainsi que sur leurs capacités
cognitives.
Un rêve pour plusieurs, mais
sans doute inaccessible.
- Le gros désavantage, c'est
qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
régulation sur l'espace.
L'espace appartient à tout
le monde, ça c'est très bien,
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas de
régulation, mais en même temps,
là, on a l'impression qu'il
appartient simplement
aux milliardaires et ca
c'est gênant en fait.
- Le coût du voyage n'a pas été
dévoilé, mais selon un rapport
gouvernemental, il s'établirait
à plus de 200 millions
de dollars américains,
soit plus de 50 millions
de dollars le siège.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, M